she's coming battle stations everyone
she wants to make art and trouble by the
looks of it
we're going to get a whole lot of both
the new cruella film brings together the
best of hair
makeup costumes and performers for an
incredible journey
one costume piece has over 5 000
individual petals hand
sewn onto it curious as to what
distraction was disturbing the animal
performers
we're diving into all the behind the
scenes magic bringing us the story of
estella
cruella oh cruella
is such a legendary role it's tough for
anyone to step into those evil shoes
considering how high the bar has been
set in previous iterations
so how has the experience been for emma
stone according to the actress
it's been nothing short of an incredible
journey what we'll get to see in this
origin story is multiple layers of a
character
and a real duality between estella and
cruella
there's two sides of her hair you know
there's kind of like the dark and the
light
emma stone has said that as cruella
she's really embraced the idea of her
nature and allowed it to lead the
character choices
she paid special attention to finding
how much of cruella is in a stella
and how much of a stella is in cruella
it's not just the actor that makes the
character though
in this case the hair makeup and
costumes played a central role in
bringing cruella to life
once you put those things on you feel
like cruella deville
in fact one of the best parts of stone's
day was undergoing the epic makeover
she just automatically felt like she was
the character
considering how dramatic and elaborate
the looks we've seen are
we don't blame her stone has admitted to
going a little bit crazy with selfies
when she wore all the outfits and
honestly we can't blame her i did a lot
of my like
you know it would be selfie central for
us too
while we're all super excited to see
just how estella went from being an
orphan child to cruella stone is of
course not the first to take on the
character
she actually got to speak to glenn close
about her experience doing the role so
many years prior early in their creation
process
she's the greatest to ever do it so
since close is an executive producer for
the film it makes sense she'd share some
words of wisdom for the next cruella
well what can i say accidents will
happen
as we've seen from so much of the promo
for the movie fashion plays a
huge role so special attention was paid
to it
fashion without was omnipresent
we've not only got the origin story of
cruella but the iconic images of
extraordinary fashion from throughout
the decades
they had award-winning costume designer
jenny bevin at the helm
who used inspiration from fashion icons
from various decades including the 1800s
the early 1900s and
of course the 70s bevin had purchased
loads of pieces from stores in new york
london and los angeles many of which
were tried on by stone in her home in la
over a
four hour session it was very
narcissistic day
which is perfect for cruella as we would
expect the experience of wearing the
larger than life outfits was extremely
fun
most of these original vintage pieces
didn't actually make the final cut
but they did provide inspiration for
costumes built for the movie
while it took many months to create all
these outfits many only ended up being
seen in the movie
for just a few seconds as for the famous
dalmatian code at the end of the film
no worries dog lovers the print is
completely fabricated and
no animals were harmed in the making of
the film we've been gawking endlessly
over the epic outfit reveal
you know the one when cruella casually
asks for a light and sets her billowing
white cape ablaze only to reveal
one of the baroness's old dresses with
improvements done by cruella herself
it's an extraordinary transformation so
how did they pull it off
the magic of cgi they considered using
tools like fire wires and fire resistant
fabrics but
in the end the vfx route was what was
both safest for the cast
as well as what looked best considering
how detailed the clothing was and how
long it took to create the wardrobe
we don't blame them for choosing to keep
these pieces away from any real flame
[Music]
it's pretty surprising to know that many
of the impressive images were created
using only practical effects
one of the most incredible being the
garbage truck dress
see how it billows and waves behind her
as the truck goes
it's almost snake-like putting it on was
just like
mind-blowing in a 40-foot train the
40-foot train was of course too heavy to
actually be attached to the dress so
the train was added after emma stone was
already set up on the truck
when the truck started we got real-life
magic
another example of amazing practical
effects involved emma stone on yet
another vehicle check out how
effortlessly stone maneuvers the giant
dress that covers pretty much the whole
car
so how exactly did they manage a large
piece that could be manipulated
so easily the answer was five
thousand and sixty individual hand sewn
petals attached by
many of the sixty people in the costume
department if we weren't already
impressed
we definitely are now we can't talk
about cruella without acknowledging some
of these epic makeup looks
intense blacks whites and of course this
signature red
another award-winning member of the team
was nadia stacy the lead makeup artist
who'd actually worked on stone before
for the film the favorite
stacy has somehow taken an iconic look
and given it new life through this film
taking inspiration from glenn close's
version of cruella as well as historical
punk styles
it was just kept making sure we never
went too far with that making sure it
never became cliche
clearly a lot of creative liberty and
freedom was used to create these
artistic and liberated looks
looking to recreate some of these styles
stacy used mac cosmetics to hit all the
right notes and in fact
mac actually created a full special line
inspired by the film
according to stacey the line is all
about fun freedom and just being
yourself
we can't wait to get our hands on these
palettes and those lipsticks
naturally there were plenty of pups on
the cruella film set
the movie may be filled with incredible
performers but if the cast were to vote
on their favorite cast members
we have the feeling the dogs would win
having the animals on set of course
brought
a great and fun energy to the room which
the actors loved
but at times they were loving it a bit
too much
and actually wound up being a
distraction for their furry co-stars
the actors were eager to bond with the
dogs and had to be deterred from
disturbing them too much with play and
dog talk the trainers were often needing
to tell the actors to leave the dogs
alone since they too were there to do a
job
while they are all professionals and the
actors did give the dogs the space they
needed
we can't blame them for wanting to hang
out with these sweet and energetic pups
though that is one place where the dogs
let the crew down
they looked too happy and delightful cgi
was actually used to make the dog's
faces look a bit nastier for the movie
oh and as for the other animal actors we
can't forget the rat that made a guest
appearance as well
a major part of what made working on the
film so special was the intensely
collaborative nature of it
the team really had the best of the best
doing exactly what they are best at
the director craig gillespie was
extremely collaborative with all the
different teams
and especially with the two leads for
emma stone and emma thompson
working together was a bit of a dream
come true the two had actually spent
what was described as a
very fun weekend together a few years
ago and both have been fans of each
other ever since
she's my favorite young american since
they're such fans of each other
getting to collaborate bringing two
strong dramatic
and extremely theatrical women to life
was a memorable experience for both
emma's
she's incredible to
act with because hey she's emma thompson
the whole crew
is kind of a dream team so it's no
surprise that most team members have
described working on this movie
as incredible all right we should put on
some music or something
the music we hear in the film actually
plays a really integral role in telling
the story and painting the scene of the
70s london it takes place in
about 48 different songs are used in the
film covering a wide range from doris
day
to nina simone to queen the director
craig gillespie would actually often
have music playing over scenes and would
make suggestions on the go as to how
they could be incorporated
like this scene that has emma stone
singing along to the classic nancy
sinatra song
this moment was born spontaneously when
gillespie had the idea
they played the music for stone shot at
once and it wound up making the cut
while a lot of old classic songs are
included the soundtrack also features a
brand new song from florence in the
machine called
call me cruella a perfect catchy theme
song for this epic film
the maniacal car driving scene is so
well known and from what we've seen
the production really delivers the car
looks so similar to the one in the
animated version and according to actor
joel fry
the car can go impressively fast it's
actually a pretty rare car as well with
only a handful that still exist
if anyone wondered whether or not that
scene was shot with green screen
checking out behind the scenes footage
we can see that it's in fact
very real honestly what can't emma stone
do
so numbers-wise what exactly did it take
to bring the epic disney film to life
let's break it down for starters the
movie cost about
200 million dollars to make we wonder
how much of that was for the costume
budget
they had hired 60 people to be on the
costume team and creating
all those looks took them a full four
months to pull off
all this done before their 14 weeks of
shooting in london
emma stone has a whopping 47 costume
changes and emma thompson follows close
behind with 33.
we can't forget the wigs though
especially since there were 240 used for
the movie
it makes sense that 37 people were on
hair and makeup teams for the two emmas
alone
seeing all that's gone into the creation
of this film makes us even more excited
for this legendary super villain to take
the screen
we're not sure what we're more excited
for though emma stone's performance or
her pup co-stars
which of corella's outfits is your
favorite